- [Instructor] This is a
prize-winning Himalayan rabbit,
and it will help us see
that an organism's traits
aren't only the results
of which genes they have,
but also which environmental factors
the organism is exposed to.
So we're gonna look at a specific gene
in the Himalayan rabbit
known as the C-gene,
and to C-gene encodes a
protein which acts as an enzyme
in the eventual production of pigment.
And we can see where that
enzyme is more active,
at the nose, on the feet,
on the ears right over here,
and then you could also
see that it is inactive
across the body and in
some parts of the head
right over here.
Now the question is
what's causing it to be
inactive or active?
Well, it turns out that the
enzyme that the C-gene codes for
is optimally active at 15 degrees Celsius
to 25 degrees Celsius,
and this alone can actually explain
the difference in pigmentation.
How does that make sense?
Well imagine that this rabbit over here
was raised at 20 degrees Celsius.
The body itself, it's a
mammal, it's warm blooded,
it's going to be producing heat.
So the body, this area right
over here, is going to be warm.
And so, over here where we're
going to be greater than,
let's say 35 degrees Celsius,
where the enzyme that the C-gene
and codes for is inactive.
This is where it's optimally active,
and above 35 degrees Celsius
it's actually not active at all.
And once again, why is
it so warm over here?
It's not just the ambient temperature.
It's the combination of
the ambient temperature
plus the heat from the rabbit itself.
Now, if you go at some
of the further off parts
of the rabbit's body,
and this is actually true
of our bodies as well,
if you go to the ears, you go to the nose,
you go to the feet, you
have less body warmth.
And so, it is going to be cooler
in these parts of the body,
and it could be cool enough
so that the protein encoded by the C-gene
is actually active.
And so, you see something very simple
can create this very neat
and, I would have to say,
cute pattern as well.
Now, some of you might be wondering, well,
could I then based on temperature,
raise a completely white Himalayan rabbit,
and the answer is yes.
If you had a twin of this rabbit
and you raised it in an environment
that was, say, hotter
than 30 degrees Celsius,
well then all of its
body would probably be
of a temperature where the
protein encoded by the C-gene is
not too active or not active at all,
and it would be a white rabbit.
And people have performed this experiment
over 100 years ago and
they saw that exact result.
And temperature is just
one of many factors.
So there's research where
they're able to make
a Cyclops fish, a fish with one eye,
based on chemicals and
where it was reared.
There's experiments with
the light that depending on
the light or the lack of light,
at the caterpillar stage,
it can affect what the
butterfly looks like
when it develops wings.
Food can activate or
inactivate certain genes,
not just in other animals,
but even in our own bodies.
There's research around fasting
and how that might activate
or inactivate certain genes.
Stress can affect genes.
Hormones can affect genes.
So the big takeaway here
is an organism's traits
are not just due to which
genes the organism has,
but are influenced by
environmental factors as well.